[Music]
in mosquito news scuitto mosquito screed
oh why doe submitted by pete's are
starbucks and animal rights activists
wants us to let mosquitoes drink our
blood well they already do so so they're
like just let it drink it not kill it
pretty much cuz right now I think
there's a mosquito like epidemic there's
so many [ __ ] mosquitoes I don't know
what the hell is happening see all of us
probably got a bite cuz I got like 10 on
me dude I'm I I'm waiting for mosquito
Hitler to rise yeah we can be behind
mosquito get there you want to be behind
him why won't I want to follow me I
wanna be like straight genocide on the
mosquitoes yeah I don't understand the
purpose of this all be is Joseph
Goebbels I don't know what you thought
you meant I really liked he met an
actual mosquito becoming a Hitler and
killing all of humanity and I was like
you want to be behind it all the way
around should watch more Pixar cartoons
because I wish I had I pictured a cute
little mosquito Hitler anyway I've been
killing the other mosquito yeah that's
good what he's dude though yeah yeah but
he's cute Oh cuz he's killing his own
just like Hitler okay cuz I heard that
Hitler was Jewish that's it yeah yeah
well anyways moving on finally Jesus
well mosquito mosquito yeah there didn't
exist so we don't have yet all right so
this french TV presenter and animal
rights activist
he claims that or recently he was urging
people not to kill mosquitoes but
instead to let them bite them and drink
their blood because he puts it as blood
donations for these mosquito mothers
just trying to nourish her children
let's spread malaria guys so does he
walk around with a bunch of like sweet
[ __ ] all over him and then just be like
let go to town to you would it work do
they do what do you think about that
sounds very Canadian just like he had
it's like let hide me hey enough no I
I hate mosquitoes so every time I see
them I actually see why I would follow
it till I kill it
damn Haley don't try to kiss him off
again
no don't want to do it no I really hate
mosquitoes cuz like my body reacts to
them and get super like itchy are you
allergic to their fight yeah - like
really big mammy - I don't like I don't
like mosquitoes even though I'm like
Canadian should I go where right here
not mosquitoes I would think there's
some kind of racism with mosquitoes
because I will go outside with Nicki for
the same amount of time I'll get three
bites she gets 60 that's me and her they
love getting like 50 of them and she
gets maybe - yeah but it doesn't work
because we're both minorities whereas
he's not the minority you mean the most
he has darker skin than you so maybe
that's what it is I think it's a dark I
think it's a darker skin so the mosquito
thinks she's white because she's nice to
meet you that makes a lot of sense
because it would mean Casey he doesn't
get as much bites as I do you use
lighter than me like a polka the same
right now he's pretty tan they like that
mocha though I was like blood type or
something that's why they would bite
more I mean that's that's the educated
scientific thing but no I don't think
it's blood yeah yeah it's body heat and
it's how much yeah breathe out or
whatever is obviously the color of their
skin
oh it's the co2 yeah
breathing out who so that attracts them
body heat I'm never breathing out again
yeah so what you probably generate some
more body heat than you that means I
breathe more than Casey either yeah all
right always told me it's cuz I had
really sweet blood she made me feel
could be cute Mama's been oh yeah
and I forgot what the other one was but
yeah what a body because my body hates
waiting more than Nicki's that's for
sure
Nicki's a cool person that's true me too
well maybe she breathes harder than you
could be I'm kind of like I I think it's
[ __ ] stupid just cuz uh though what
the mom needs nourishment so like we
should let all the burglars come into
our house because they're stealing food
- but I miss - good bye you better have
a bunch of cockroaches in his apartment
I know I'm okay with Jenna citing
mosquitoes like I don't know if they
really have a purpose and they're all
invasive like they didn't really exist
especially like in Hawaii and stuff like
that or do they come from
is it a mutation the
basic so I think oh I think they're
there they're mainly from Africa and
then they get on to like the trading
ships and then it goes to different
countries and then yeah yes a huge thing
I know that you say Africa mm-hmm but
they come from Pangaea Pangaea like when
all the countries are melded together
yeah okay cuz they were around back then
there's prehistoric mosquito they're
like big dude they were around with the
dinosaurs and [ __ ] didn't you watch
Jurassic Park
that was member or stuck in the amber oh
yeah oh yeah I saw it like that
cyclopædia and then I didn't I know
watching movies no because I um you know
my research and ass like I checked I was
like what did the natives like Native
Hawaiians do to deal with mosquitoes
right cuz I'm like they didn't have
something like that bucking repellent
they didn't have any of that so like how
did they deal with this [ __ ] cuz it just
doesn't seem like I don't know it
doesn't seem like practical right for
them to live like this and they didn't
have any [ __ ] defense and then I read
it's a recent thing so that they spread
throughout the Pacific Islands and all
that and it might be Asia I just made up
Africa but I really like it they weren't
originally from there like it's just a
recent thing so then it's okay if all of
them die is it really but what eats
mosquitoes like is that whatever's
eating it will die too if I think so for
like lizards and length I don't think
anybody's eating mosquitoes that's why
there's so many oh no yeah but bats are
not doing a good job yeah or the lizards
or whoever supposed to be eating them
aren't doing a very good job well that's
why they they're trying to work on a
mosquito birth control thing where let's
play Skrillex
yeah that one too wait what the hell are
you talking about the recently we talked
about how this one particular Skrillex
song can like make the mosquitoes go
crazy and don't they die I forgot either
that or they just want to [ __ ] oh yeah
blast that [ __ ] everywhere Felix no yep
that's really good oh he like made it he
just sort of said he's like how do I
kill this kid he's the Hitler to
mosquitoes he could be our leader he
could be just has the Skrill expect yeah
this dude back to this French guy he's
saying that it's embarrassing for anti
species who realized they are being
attacked by a mother trying to nurse her
future children
reporter on a new station so he's saying
that animal lovers should allow insects
to bite them except in countries like
Africa where they were risk contracting
diseases like malaria so at least he
does draw a line somewhere this reminds
me of this episode of Walking Dead when
they were zombie rights activists where
people like you should let them eat you
because they need to survive these are
the type of people that I've drained
their death well he should create is his
little legions of followers and stuff so
that those people could get fit and then
just go away it's like this is like when
you hear about burglar who falls through
somebody's skylight and now he's suing
him yeah then he wins and he's like
there's unsafe conditions American theme
we love suing it I think in California
actually mm-hmm yes if someone breaks
into your house in California and then
while they're burglarizing your home
they fall and they get hurt they could
say hey I got hurt in your house I'm
gonna sue you and they could win you
know and it's happened before
trespassing or no that's not well yeah
no it is but then they're saying that's
a separate thing yeah it's not a
criminal they don't have a criminal
complaint against you they have a civil
complaint against you Wow so they're
like you're your marble floors are very
extra slippery no huh we have stupid
laws so if you see a criminal about to
fall fall first but then if you're in
your own home you're screwed so what you
should do is follow them to their house
and then injure yourself break it to
their house and then fall in their house
be like no I'm gonna countersue because
you have unsafe floors yeah and then go
in their fridge and eat old eggs anyway
all bad sex [ __ ] down like fine expired
milk just yeah yeah you got a try you
got yeah yeah no wonder they're
burglarizing homes look at the food they
have in the fridge no poor guys anyway
so everyone's talking about this guy
saying like what this is this is going
too far
it is too far we don't need to treat
mosquitoes like they have rights and
[ __ ] you don't have right you know I'm
not against his thoughts
I think he should express it in a way
that helps people so like he should go
to tropical places and be the mosquito
food for
the tourists like he should follow tour
groups and be like have a flag for the
mosquitos to know that he's like a
buffet and in so the mosquitoes would
just go to him and everyone else won't
get bit I wonder if you could die from
just mosquito bites not only the
diseases but like a bit drain so much of
your blood I just wonder what that would
look like if you have a welts like all
over like hives just all over your body
recently got a mosquito bite and then it
infected her brain somehow oh my god did
you think it was funny what you think it
was funny you laugh at her you don't
laugh at other people's pain in Canada
no definitely not
why oh it's kind of funny if you think
about it look because I so she got bit
and then she said I've got a lot of
headaches apparently for like a cup like
two weeks and then she's like this is
getting serious and then they found that
her brain was like infected or something
like something along with like that I
also was like something from the blood
yeah so that's why I kill mosquitoes
hell yeah look I hate them
is it popular in Canadian films to have
like a comedy movie where a guy gets hit
in the nuts and then he like doubles
over and pained everyone laughs yeah
yeah I don't know if it's in Canadian
who am i think it's a good TV so they
kick him in the nuts and everyone goes
oh yeah they're like oh okay and they
write a letter to the station about how
hoping that he's okay probably yeah
probably
well who do that's nice well I'm song it
hasn't evolved it hurts right so I I
don't know if I would laugh I'll do like
oh no are you okay oh we were so close I
thought no I thought that you would find
that funny
not really what if a guy is he climbed a
tree right and then he slips and he
falls out 18 branches but his balls hit
every branch dude he laughs okay a
little bit American to that extreme like
every branch that has bothering they
never yes I guess I would be like oh my
god you're so unlucky like that every
break even after he hits one if he falls
down this way come back comes back on
its master
I guess it was repetitive yeah I guess
oh wow and a squirrel comes and punches
on that that's yeah that would probably
feather priming and raccoon bites him in
the yeah and then in the next scene he's
like with Cameron Diaz and like they're
making love and they're like that gets
it all worked out and then she punches
in at the end that to be you should see
who she married do you believe it and
its uses his calm for a facial
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]